i could just ban anyone who's suggesting
you two
that would kind of be mean though oh
subscriber only chat could be
interesting too
because then there there might be less
trolls i don't know how many of my
subscribers are trolls
but that could be interesting
so we're going to try one game against
subs only
it actually doesn't really matter the
time control as long as there's
increments
like 2 plus 30 3 plus 30.
okay oh should i should i play the bong
cloud
what opening what opening should i play
i'll play london
london time oh should i flip the board
let's do a poll yes no
um okay oh
so many people want the board flipped
okay i'll flip the board
okay chat you got your wish
c5 may be coming i
i kind of understand that you want to
see things from your perspective
and not from my perspective
wow c5 i feel like i'm playing against
myself
oh should i do blindfold i'll do another
poll once this one finishes
i'm very impressed no one voting for
king d7
so we're not having like a
what is it called
a flipped reverse bond cloud
okay pull okay so people wanted the
board flipped
blindfold yes
no also i'm impressed chad is playing
like main main line
ooh 61
want the blindfold okay
i guess the blindfold is going on
any miracle to come back
maybe not yeah if you're on mobile you
might not be able to see the poll
okay blindfolds going on goodbye world
goodbye chat let's turn back on sound
speech synthesis ready bishop d6
now now i'm not sure i'm probably going
to visualize the position from white's
perspective
i could visualize it from black's
perspective
[Music]
wait i i just need to flip the board
once okay
okay so bishop d6 let's play bishop g3
bishop g3 okay okay blind time
yeah it's i think it would be weird to
play a mindful game looking from the
wrong perspective
it's probably not too much different but
just more comfortable looking from
white's perspective
and this is a main line anyway so like
this position that we currently have
kingside castle has been just implanted
in my mind
i'll play uh my main prep bishop b5 yeah
so bishop b5
um the main line is actually bishop d3
but bishop b5 is it's kind of a move
that's been pioneered by carlson
he won some nice games in it
my first the first video of my london
course
i talk about this line i show a carlson
game
a6 a6 yeah this is one of the moves
let's take bishop takes c6
so this would be like the ideal moment
to see if there's any
trolls i'm really curious but i'm not
gonna peak
c6 yeah black has one obvious move
queen a4 the whole idea of this bishop
e5 moves is to get this position
um there's some there's some positional
drops
and some tactical traps and we'll see
how
how prepared black is
or how prepared chad is
queen c7 um so
yeah it's interesting um queen c7 might
be the most played move on each s
but it's a mistake because first i can
take on
d6 bishop takes d6 and now i can play
queen e3
and going back to when i played bishop
e5 like this is one of the main main
points
is basically to trap black in this line
queen takes c6
queen a3 queen a3
now the pawn pawn on c5 is pinned
i've had this position probably close to
a dozen times
a few times in like over-the-board blitz
tournaments
a few times online most people play
knight
knight d7
and then knight b3 knight b3 will
actually win the pawn
queen b8 oh queen v8 ooh
that's a tricky move never seen that
move before
so if i take on c5 with a pawn i lose b2
so i'll take with the queen queen takes
c4
no no no i confuse myself
i'm i've meant to flip at the say the
other thing
i meant to say if i take what the queen
i lose upon if i take with a pawn i'm
safe
i just completely confuse myself
it's still probably okay for me if i can
just castle
queen takes b2 i've never done that
before though
i think i just made the mistake because
i'm i'm talking like
trying to talk and move at the same time
kingside
castles man
okay so at least my knights communicate
idea rooksy one it's equal material
idea rook b1
we might see knight d7
bishop d7 hmm there's a d7 it's a sad
bishop
but it defends the pawn
queen b4 queen trade
i wouldn't mind the queen trade and
queen was annoying on b2
this is another moment i'm very curious
what the split is
between queen takes b4 and queen c2
queen c2 is like a a bold
kind of adventurous move queen takes v4
is like the obvious
simple decision uh why can't i type
cb4 see takes b4 man so
i could have been up a fawn i confused
myself i lost the pawn back
now we have some kind of more positional
end game um
i'm happy with that trade though because
now c5
is a nice nice order
for my knight look what rook ab8
rook a b8 let's play a3 a3
this is definitely a higher level game
i feel like sub only chad is much
stronger than
normal chat no offense to the plebs
so the idea the idea very soon is knight
b3 a5 oh a5 good move
shot's playing really well huh
so i could play rook fb1 i could take on
a5
and i would probably lose a pawn back
all i want to do is get my knight to
a nice square let's try taking on a5
it's interesting
b takes a5 i temporarily go up upon
uh black's gonna try and win it back
either with rook b5 or rook b8
or maybe something else and then
i'll try something like a4 a combination
of a4 knight b3 knight c5
i'm giving away my plans b5 they're kind
of hard to stop
so yeah rook b5 i'll play a4 a4 and then
i'll go for knight b3
this is definitely going to be a more
hard fought game
there's no queens of sacrifice there's
no king to bond cloud
rook takes a5 camp on cloud your king
after castling wait what rook takes a5
okay
okay so knight b3 knight b3
so the pawn's still on c6 which is nice
so my dear
probably my next move is knight knight
c5
i've got my trusty water okay seven
didn't get around to making t
rook a7 okay a7 so i could play a5
too let's play knight c5 knight c5
and c5 helps uh defend the pawn as well
yeah water water is basically flavorless
tea
it can be refreshing very hydrating
so i think there's there's a decent move
here for cafe eight
wait what rook f a8 rook fa-8
interesting okay so it's very positional
i'm going to play 95
knight e5 i was thinking about could
play knight
e4 but maybe that wasn't so good i just
take and play knight d2
now the bishop's hit bishop is defended
though
bishop is defended twice
but that basically means that the rook
on e7 and the knight on f6 are tied down
bishop e8 um
[Music]
that's interesting so the idea i guess
plaque wants to play
maybe mobilize the knight
f3
play f3 f4 no
ah that's ah i like to say
i can't even offer a take back
blindfolded i don't know if chad could
accept a take back either
f4 is not a blunder i don't think it's
just
a slightly undesirable positional move
f3 was so nice restricting the knight f4
now gives a knight
uh yeah this potential outpost square
oh my pawn's still on a4
so i think what i'll do
oh this is tricky
i play brook rook off c1
we trade
we'll play knight play knight ed3 knight
ed3
there's some risk involved with this
but i think it's a decent decision
it's definitely a bigger challenge f6
f6 okay let's i should take that
let's take it knight takes e4 and pawn
takes e4 and then knight
knight c5 and coming
i was more scared instead of f6 i was
scared of knight c3
i'm sure there are some votes for that
move
yeah so once my knight he takes e4 gets
to c5 knight c5
it's just a beautiful night against a
miserable bishop
white has pawns both e pawns are
attacked now
paul 94 is still defended
probably expecting something
oh king f7
i have no intention of taking either e
pawn
f5 also possible
you're gonna play brook play rook fd1
rook fb1
this is the only open file it's a b file
this bishop on e8 it's just kind of
blocked by its pawns
the question is how does white actually
make progress
because the pieces are pretty
king f7 but i have to improve
to do something to improve the position
i guess i'll start with king f2
king f2 oh so i have a pawn on f4
black has pawns c6 e6 f5 e4
g7 h7 this could be a long game
that's not easy to crack
king f6 let's play h3
h3 going for probably going for g5
or um g4
i'm realizing i have some idea of rook
b6
pretty sure black's rooks are on
e7 h678
h6 let's uh play g4 g4
i'm not sure this is like objectively
the best approach
maybe i could have prepared this more
but i'm i'm thinking eventually i'll
i'll bring my rook
to g5 g5 wow
what's g5 g5
so my ideas are being copied
maybe king g3
g3 simple move king g3
and then my rook wants to come to f1 i
think this is a plan
rock f1 open that file do some damage
the whole chat is probably stream
sniping
can you stop it h5
h5 what is this h5 is a hilarious
move and probably not a bad move
but i could okay i can take on oh
here's what i can do i can play f g5 f
takes g5 check
h4 and then g5 myself
it's just more positionally positional
domination
if the king doesn't take on g5 then i'll
still be happy
and then my f1
g5 okay h4 h4 check
yeah king is beautifully placed on g3
this is so this is this bishop on e8
it's so sad because it can't move to h5
it can't move to c6
and there's pawns on f5 e4 so it can
really never find happiness
g6
play g i'm actually not sure if i want
to play g5 because i can also take
maybe taking is more attractive
yeah let's take on h5 g takes h5 check
i was so excited to get this song this
past
like defended past pawn on g5 but now
i'm realizing
the prospect of the open g file is
probably just more valuable
combined with the prospect of king f4
this is actually h5 let's say that was
another interesting moment because king
f6 was a
possibility so i'm playing a four
a very nice square for the king
guys can we stop blocking our bishop
this bishop still so sad on e8 but it
does have what this g82 diagonal
if it goes to f7 king h6
king h6 ah so the idea
wait why king h6 is that a free pawn
i probably don't even want to take on a
5 though
i just want to play rook or g1
rook g1 i'm cutting off the king
yeah cutting off the king
hmm maybe at the right moment
like 96 beginning to look for mating
ideas
rook g7 that's logical
so if i take
oh i have a nice move yeah let's just
take
rook takes g7
i'm gonna play a f where's my pawn a5
yeah okay king king g7 is coming
hey thanks for subbing i shall no longer
be a pleb i shall join my brethren in
playing against thee
oh king takes g7 that sounds threatening
king takes g7 g7 okay
a5 so the beautiful thing is
my knight is still on c5 my rook's on a1
black rook is on a and bishop on e8 king
on g7
um
i'm controlling a6 with the knight so a6
will come
once i get the pawn to a6 my rook can
can be free
king f6
ooh i have to be careful not to get
mated
chat wants to mate me with eventual
eventual rook g4
wait a minute i have a pawn i still have
a pawn on h4
yeah because black never took it
wait king f6 king f6 so my knights on c5
so like worst case scenario
i have knight e4
let's start with a6 a6
it's crazy that i have to be worried
about mate in the end game
with my king on such a nice square
but that's the case when you're like
kind of sandwiched between claws
these f5 e4 pawns are dangerous
so i'm guessing probably like bishop
some bishop move is coming
bishop h5 yeah like that bishop move
so now if i play
if i play ace wait i played bishop h5
a6 bishop h5 oh this is crazy so if i
play
it might work i could play a7
and then
this is where i don't want to calculate
out loud i'm considering a7 here
i think it works
oh no it doesn't work
this is crazy so i wanted to play a7
rook g8
knight takes e4 pawn takes e4 and then
queen
but rook g4 is still mate
this is very devious let's play rook g1
rook g1 eric don't worry about whether
it works
i i always have to worry it's terrifying
i might get mated and i'm on the verge
of promoting
there's a line where i promote and then
get mated
don't want to have any of that
i have to defend my glory 13 bishop e2
i should eat two
oh my pawn
that's a good move
i didn't realize chad is capable of
playing good moves
[Music]
i'm 97
97 is another consideration oh wait i
know i have
a counter good move rook g5
rook g5 there we go see what happens
when we can move all of our pieces
yeah your bishop came to life
by i'm i'm still happy with rook g5
you can have my a pawn i'll have your e
and f funds
yeah we could get into this takes a6
some scenario like
takes f5 check i'm winning the center
pawns
my knight is still a monster
i could take on a6 eventually
white 13 minutes 38 seconds
black 5 minutes 54 seconds
plenty of time
he takes f5
wait what there's an e pawn
oh no takes f5 check it takes f5
oh no
this rookie g bishop takes a6 and my e5
takes
f5 check i forgot there is an e pawn
everyone type f in the chat to pay your
respects
everyone type something that blunders
some material back i need a miracle
no let's play knight g7
wait knight d7 why can't i move
when it's on d7 right
can i not move
white 12 minutes 47 seconds
black six minutes 10 seconds knight
d7
eric you fast forward
i fast forward he takes oh
he takes f5 knight d7
okay thanks for that i got confused
you need to move the position forward
eric i
i i had to rewind reality
because i didn't believe what happened
and now i kind of believe it
so that whole time i was envisioning
there
not being a pawn on e6
so rick g5 made no sense oh that's so
bad
king e6 i was so proud of rook g5 2
like king e6
knight c5 check check draw
i forget if leachat's auto claims a
threefold
i actually don't know if it does
it's my only hope right now
don't feel bad eric you have a lot on
your plate and
it's easy to lose concentration
knight d7 check okay we're on the verge
i i have some hope of not losing
chat's already played king d6 or king um
yeah king d6 once sorry eric chat still
loves you
oh i love you too chad i know it's king
e6
king's going back and forth between e6
and f6
king g6 ah
uh 95 knight e5 check so we didn't
repeat that position
but maybe we'll repeat this position
i don't know if it's sent a draw offer
if i type draw
i don't know what i did there night
knight e5 check
white 14 minutes 13 seconds
black six minutes five seconds
king h5
oh that's a good move too
or is it i don't know i'll take this
king takes f5 i'm gonna lose h pawn
there's gonna be some weird end game
man so i'm winning i could be winning
the rest of the pawns
the king's on h5
so basically the c pawn and the e pawn
are hanging
king takes h4 okay
question is which pawn do i take first
i actually don't know
let's take the epong first king takes e4
center pawn is more
more valuable and bishop d3 was maybe
coming
okay so i'm i'm controlling the center
even though i'm down the rook
black has rook on a8 bishop on a6 i have
pawns e3 d4
king on e4 not in e5 bishop b5
bishop e5 is a very wise move
defending
defending the pawn
maybe i'll try king i'll try king f5
eric the first miss the deep stare of
your mahogany brown eyes
oh it was very poetic
there is no pawn on c6 really
yes there is wait is there not
pretty sure there is rook f8 check
there's no pawn on c6 and that's even
nicer but i'm pretty sure there's
it's like king e6 king e6
yeah because the bishop was always stuck
behind the pawn from e8
okay trying to make progress
this is intense man chats played well up
until this point though
you're playing like a solid 1900
probably
rookie 8 check for e8
i want to play king g7 but then c5 would
be very devious
maybe king
enjoy eric love your content oh thank
you
king d6 i appreciate that
don't destroy me too much
okay so i have all my things on dark
spurs
pawns e3 d4 knight e5 and king now on d6
it works on e8 i might be
threatening my threatening to take the
pawn king g3
i might want to take the pawn
knight takes c6 yeah there was a pawn on
c6 i knew
it okay so i won the pawn
so black has no more pawns
now the question is
will i survive
but it should really be a statement i
will survive
bishop takes c6 okay we're trading king
c6
king takes c6 actually don't know the
evaluation here
i'm supposed to shoulder the king
i don't have any shoulder pads
it's actually nice the king can't move
to f4
because i have a pawn on e3
hmm this feels like an end game study
rook takes e3 okay let's play
oh that was a good move let's play d5 d5
oh it's such a close race i'm trying to
calculate
but i want to calculate out loud in case
i reveal like a win
but it's all up to chat because chat has
only only a winning chance three
check rook c3 yeah that's tricky move
so i think what i want to do
is play it seems weird but king b7
moving away from the pawn
but still within range of defending the
pawn
wait a minute
i i've have to calculate
how much time do i have white
16 minutes three seconds black
seven minutes six seconds this this
might be one of those weird endgame
studies where i'm supposed to move in
front of the pawn
which would be crazy it might be one of
those ideas for these two where i'm just
lost
i'm just trying to invent hope
so i wanted to play king b7
but then
king b7 just imagine like king f4
d6 key five d7
rep d2 king c7 it's it's drawn no king
b7 should be drawn
how else does black try king d7
there's no
either you draw or you lose the choice
is yours bro seiden
wait so there's there's one thing i'm
concerned about though
so i move there there there
there no it's losing
so what if i do
[Music]
man
so if i do this there there
there there
wait where's the rook rook c3 check c3
okay
so i'm actually i'm considering i'm
considering king d7 here
king d7 king f4
k7 king f4
oh no do i have to under promote tonight
pd7 king f4 uh
d16e5 king e7 rook h2
d7 rook h7 kingy a king six then i have
to under chrome tonight
and i get tortured here for several
moves
but king d7 should draw
because i have to shoulder the king
d7 king f4 d6
king d5 should make a difference
oh maybe it does though
ooh
no i'm losing every line
and i just revealed the whole line to
the chat too
except not the final move
that's insane
now king d7 is losing
d7 king f4
d6 oh no no it's not losing
the king can't move from f4 to d5 i was
thinking that king could move to d5 this
should be drawn
eric under promoting d7
yeah more like under promotion for the
draw
i i hallucinated for a moment there i
thought the king could get to d5
but it's not in time
so yeah now i can speak freely because i
think we're going to see the under
promotion line
king f4 making f4 d6 d6
that was a weird hallucination i guess i
just assumed that king could get to the
fifth rank
i was too lazy to see which which square
but we'll see if chad can actually like
figure out this under promotion line
i'm sure some people followed
king e7 yeah so i was actually
envisioning the king on d5 in this
position where rookie 2 would be winning
now i'm i'm trying to remember how
promoting works
because i know how i have auto queen
turned on
but i'm pretty sure i would still have
to
wait what do you like king ifa king e7
rook h3
okay d7 pretty sure i would still have
to type
the promotion piece
oh this is going to be torture
but actually it's not too bad it's just
kind of annoying when you're on the
last rank rook h7 check
yeah opinions king eight
d knight maybe i should type
maybe i should type the end first
just in case there's some weird auto
queen thing
and we'll see if we'll see what uh what
black does
maybe we'll see rook takes pawn king e6
okay yeah so this this is a kind of a
well-known end game situation
where okay i'm gonna type n first oh it
won't let me type n
but maybe it will king e8
oh maybe it didn't king e6
king e6 okay so i'll have to type d8
and d8 okay let's get it in queen and
then
and d8 promotes to bishop what
no did i type b no
i typed b i meant to type n
i was even thinking like don't mouse
flip q but cues all the way on the other
side of the keyboard
don't mate me don't make me
don't do a chat
rook h checkmate checkmate
black is really great i meant to
i meant to type n that was the worst
ending
i could have asked for accidentally
under promoting to a bishop
is there a take back optim oh that's a
good question
i don't think so king e6 d8 king e6
yeah i was actually looking forward to
like defending this too
man
that went from 100 to zero real quick
i was so proud of like this calculation
too
that like i was i was basically winning
by or i'm not winning drawing by one
tempo
thanks for the game eric you all catch
up to us
one day oh thanks chat
i'll try also good job chat that's your
first win
that's your first win i guess i'm not
proud of that
um let's analyze though that was an
interesting game
hello youtube oh yeah youtube people
hope you enjoyed that that was brutal
i was really
well played chat i almost feel proud
being a part of that
good job chad
yeah i guess this is part of history
man
so first so first of all i just had a
complete brain lapse
because i was trying to say that this
loses a pawn
and this wins i played the move that
loses the point anyway
tough luck with the mistake
and then i was all proud of this moment
i saw the pawn the e6 here
i guess at some point it just it escaped
my mind it was still upon
e6
and this is still really good for lights
but then then i was scared about rochi
formate
so this is where so this is where i
wanted to play a7
um rook g4 and then knight takes e4
uh with chat and then takes and then
this
but then this is still mate but now i'm
actually realizing i could have i could
have played knight d7 here
and then this allows me to promote this
would have been the cleanest flame
i under promoted and over delivered man
okay i was writing me or no i
i was i had this amazing idea where was
it
if the king took here i would meet the
chat was smart enough i'm curious if
anyone suggested this move
and then this end game so this is still
winning for black
but then oh this is still winning
oh so yeah the king has to come back
this way right
rook takes e3 loses a crucial tempo even
though it's like the most obvious move
so i wanted so initially i wanted to
play king b7 which loses by a tempo
because i'm actually curious
uh if chat would play it though
me ask chad what would you play in this
position
maybe people were discussing this line
okay everyone knows
because the natural move is king here
but i think king here draws
the rook here i'm pretty sure wins
oh welcome back gm reigns oh some people
saying king f4
i'm pretty sure this draws but this wins
because it chases the king back to c6
and then
uh that gets a tempo in the very end
wait let's see rook d3 only winning move
so i'm curious if chad would have found
that
and the the calculation is here here
here
and because the king was forced to c6 it
has to find another move to prepare the
pawn promotion
but then it's too late
55 d5 loses
55 d5
i was on i was in check on mu 55.
the 55 king b7 loses loses to rook d3
um yeah so king g7 so this is kind of an
instructive end game
oh wait did i miss let's see
55 not 56.
yeah people can analyze this if uh if
you want some
analysis of uh of specific lines
but yeah this was all drawing until
until i under promoted why does the b
have to be next to the end
i was typing so smoothly that game i
felt like i guess i had one other slip
um
f4 instead of f3
but yeah this is a a classic draw
i had something like this like once
before in the tournament
i should have looked at the keyboard
yeah and i had the blindfold on
i usually type like decently without
looking but
sometimes when keys are next to each
other that's what happens
anyway that was fun um if this goes on
youtube
follow on twitch and i'm sure i'll do
more of this
in the future thanks so much again to
andrew chess
for uh making this possible this was
really fun i think that will be my last
game against chat
that was very uh very energy draining